I love ghostbusters I've mentioned this
more than a few times over the years the
1984 original is my favorite movie of
all time and while the sequel and the
reboot didn't do much for me there was
more to my phantom than just that first
film I had all kinds of toys from a
proton pack to a trap action figures and
of course I watched the Real
Ghostbusters years ago back when I was
still trying to make the green screen
effect work I did a video talking about
my picks for the top 10 best episodes of
this cartoon and there are many to pick
from from when Halloween was forever
which gives us this awesomely spooky
holiday monster to citizen ghosts which
gives the back story of how Slimer
became a resident of the firehouse to
the brilliantly named collect Call of
Cthulhu which Dovan to Lovecraftian lore
the show could have wacky cartoon humor
it could have fantastical leaps of
imagination
it could even be pretty legitimately
tense when it wanted to be but for me
the single best episode is the seventh
episode the first season mr. Sandman
dream me a dream oh and yeah take a
quick second to notice the name of who
wrote this J michael Straczynski as in
comic book writer J michael Straczynski
as in creator of Babylon 5 J michael
Straczynski yeah this humble and lady's
cartoon has a decent pedigree and the
writing sometimes let's dive in the
episode gives us a properly spooky
opening as this yuppie couple have a
minor spat as one of them wants to play
tennis while the other is rereading old
comics from his childhood
the woman storms off and an unseen
figure sprays rainbow glitter on the man
and my heart goes out to him I can tell
you from experience that he is never
going to get that stuff out of his
clothes
then we cut back to the woman who turns
around and gives us a legitimate
horrified scream it cuts over to the
firehouse and Peter is only just getting
out of bed and clearly had a terrible
night's sleep
he complains about weird dreams and Ray
offers the advice that if you know it's
a dream and remind yourself of that you
can sometimes take control of that dream
the bell is rung and the team head out
on a call they arrive at an eerily quiet
location and we get our first hint
that's something even weirder than usual
is going on like just take a minute to
appreciate that
cuz that's adorably bizarre I love that
the audience sees this and the
characters don't the team knocks on the
door and peter is attacked by this
tentacled be steve from the cover of the
comic Egon is reluctant to have them
fire on it at first because the readings
are just all wrong he has no idea what
the beams will do to it
make some light alterations and Winston
gets this great line like my dad always
said we learned by doing a monster
basically just poops away once it's hit
and the team find the couple from the
opening peacefully sleeping while
floating in mid-air Egon speculates that
this is not the work of a ghost but
something else altogether the team takes
a look outside and we get this madness
see this is a big part of what I love
about this episode for me many of the
best Real Ghostbusters episodes had
premises that freed up the designers and
the animators to go kind of nuts and
they clearly were given a long leash on
this one they got to go cartoony in a
whole different way and it's a blast
Egon floats the idea that what they're
dealing with is a Sandman that's right
the kind that helps people go to sleep
but this one has gone rogue and is using
sleep to us so powerful but it makes
whatever the sleeper dreams actually
manifest first off I love that Egon just
makes the leap that sand
a real without missing a beat I know
that's really because these are short
there isn't time for him to be doubting
this but it's such a bizarre leap of
logic and he makes it effortlessly and I
love that his suspicions get confirmed
as we now get to meet the Sandman who
has a simple but pretty effective
appearance it's slightly off-putting his
head's way too big he's so deathly pale
and I mean the clothes just kind of
classic he tells the team his plan is to
put people to sleep for 500 years
using this absolutely wonderfully
off-putting voice I love this voice so
much I can't even begin to tell you
especially when it shifts to how he
sounds when he doesn't get his way so we
have our set up of Dreams wandering
around as people sleep we've met our
villain we know the stakes how do we
crank it up a notch before the
commercial break oh well we have the
Sandman take everyone's dreams and turn
them into nightmares I mean look at this
everything cute and whimsical is twisted
into something scary just in time for
the act break we come back and our
heroes are on the run their proton packs
may have made sure work at the dreams
and the past but they're vastly
outnumbers and need to refocus on taking
out the Sandman himself first priority
is to get ecto-1 so they're not stuck on
foot to do that they have to take out a
monstrous version of the Easter Bunny
because why not the car won't start and
when Ray goes to check under the hood
he's ambushed by the Sandman which
immediately manifests his dream of pizza
now this could be argued as being a bit
of a fat joke and I'm not gonna say it
100 percent isn't but what I love about
this is that in a matter of seconds we
demonstrate how tricky The Sandman is
the heroes are down a member and the car
is now inaccessible that my friends is
efficient storytelling at its best
now down a man the remaining three try
to track the Sandman and that leads them
to a building guarded by a freaking
dragon this is where we get a nice
explanation of why they're not just
blasting every nightmare they come
across now that they're no longer being
swarmed every time we take out one of
those things it's like holding up a sign
saying here we are I like that there's
these little acknowledgments for how the
story goes out it's a little bit more
explanation than you would sometimes get
from this cartoon I think it shows our
respect for the intelligence of the
audience once inside the building they
make the classic mistake of splitting up
and Peter gets sleep dusted and his
dream yeah of course
oh and in case anybody thinks it's a
plot hole that Ray and Peter are having
two seemingly ordinary dreams and not
nightmares just keep in mind the Sandman
only transform the dreams that were
active at the time new dreams that have
started since he did all that they get
to kick off as normal it's not a plateau
I think way too much about these
cartoons Winstead Egon start the launch
load trudge back to the firehouse with
Egon kind of hung up on Ray's advice to
Peter way back at the start of the
episode about telling yourself it's only
a dream but right when he puts the beads
together The Sandman gets him
this leaves Winston all in his own well
on his own with Egon stream of Einstein
naturally Winston has a serious moment
of self-doubt being the only member of
the team who isn't a scientist and
doubting his ability to cope with what
is going on Einstein gives him a little
pep talk
tells him nobody needs to be a scientist
to solve a problem and just kind of
toggles off Winston continues the trek
to the firehouse and has a bolt of
lightning moment actually kind of
literally which is a little on the nose
but cool we'll roll with it
and he formulates a plan now as the
audience we don't know what he's hit on
initially and that gets strung out I
think just the right amount of time
because we jump ahead to the fire house
where he's just finishing telling Ginny
and whatever his plan is and harming her
with the spare proton pack
slacker warns them that the Sandman has
a ride and hides into a drawer Oh
insight note slammer is used just the
right amount in this episode he has a
brief appearance at the front end
basically tormenting Peter which is
really good for and then he comes in
here at the end Slimer when used
properly was really an asset to the show
later seasons which would lean on the
character so heavily that they actually
rebranded its Slimer and the Real
Ghostbusters that was just not something
that went down very well but this kind
of use where he basically is just a pet
or a mascot that lives at the firehouse
and that's pretty much the only time
that the Ghostbusters interact with them
that works fine and that's how he's used
here naturally the Sandman shows up
Winston and Janine take some shots at
him but he keeps vanishing away managing
to get behind Janine and put her to
sleep
this leaves him to close in on Winston
and gloat
although Winston has a pretty good
rebuttal to this entire scheme of his
but the whole reason people dream is so
they can try to make the dreams come
true how can they do that if they're all
asleep of 500 years things are looking
grim but guess what
Janine has been reminding herself that
she's dreaming she takes control of the
dream imagines herself as a Ghostbuster
she suits up and catches the Sandman off
guard from behind
Winston joins to pin him down and we
have possibly my single favorite moment
in the entire history of the show
[Music]
seriously that is burned into my memory
the perfect sore-loser villains scream a
terrific and very cool image and the
theme music kicking in with my favorite
part of that song right at the key
moment oh it's so good one more time
please
[Music]
I have loved that so much Slimer sends
out a trap Sandman's captured everybody
wakes up there's a little note at the
end where Winston isn't celebrating
because he's the only person who didn't
sleep so he needs to nap and that's a
wrap on this one I love so much about
this episode it has virtually everything
I enjoy about this show all wrapped up
into a single package a chance for the
designers and the animators to go both
goofy and dark with really inventive
visual gags and monsters great jokes
rooted in the characters a creative
villain that has the heroes on the
backfoot
right from the start and requires a
creative solution not a technobabble one
and as a bonus it allows jeanine to have
a hero moment and allows winston my
favorite Ghostbuster for the record the
chance to shine since the Real
Ghostbusters was an ensemble show
different episodes would sometimes
highlight different members of the team
but this is done a little differently
than in other instances usually if an
episode was going to mainly focus on one
of the Ghostbusters above the other it
becomes very clear very early on which
one it's going to be and you'll realize
within the first five minutes oh this is
a Peter episode this is a Rey episode
etc etc but here you wouldn't guess from
the front half of the show that Winston
would be the last man standing and yet
feels totally fitting totally earned and
it gives him a chance to be clever in
addition to brave which was usually his
default thing so that my friends is mr.
Sandman dream me a dream my personal
all-time favorite episode of the cartoon
The Real Ghostbusters I would seriously
be up for doing more videos like this
but it is probably gonna depend on the
response I get but this this was fun for
me and I hope it was for you as well
please like subscribe consider
supporting my patron plus I've got
another channel I've got a book bunch of
links in the description that you can
click on but you also don't have to do
any
because at the end of the day you're the
council I am only running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]